hi guys it's Gordon and starting
suddenly the 21st of July I'm going on
one of the biggest adventures I've ever
taken on my new National Geographic
series Gordon Ramsay uncharted now his
link peak and get ready for some of the
craziest scrambled egg dishes you've
ever ever seen now I've made scrambled
egg a million times I've never made it a
high-altitude
literally about two half thousand feet
above sea level so we're going to try it
here so eggs go into the goose improving
penis as well now everything is sourced
locally and for me I'm sort of this you
know no seasoned just lightly beat them
in there lightly just to sort of break
them up and then from there I'm going
look the local chilies so this is a good
time almost like a sort of wild garlic a
little bit mint in there and it's got
that amazing flavour so really old
Martinez has become the sort of beat
prudently on high altitude cooking so
and let's go use the local salt okay man
that's just cooking from the heat inside
I'm gonna make this a little more
fragrance more importantly
I'm dying to see how it tastes
high-altitude now Marilia made an
amazing sort of almost like a frittata
earlier with the most amazing I'll pack
up right now look at that okay Mona go
back onto the heat some 30 seconds I
think ten seconds things like a furnace
man back on off we could back off turn
that around now we have no butter okay
so we use a little bit yeah that's
equivalent today goose fats so to be
rendered down you have to excuse me I
have breath I've seen how a thousand
meters nicely he put me up a tree last
week yeah that's right
climbing trees for mangoes and I said
that process down by literally adding a
touch of the local cream in
just come out scrape all sides down it's
still a little bit runny but back in
there that's the local salt from the
salt mines pink salt
get that in there chilli starting to
render down I've got a little touch of
chamomile in that salt as well
and now there she goes now it's coming
together
okay now she's come for free
such a cream in there now we mix this
let's take it off the heat let's bring
it out to the table Thank You sirs
please please wooden spoons Edie's booth
stolen these amazing mouth-breathers job
look what's happened to me putting
flowers on a scrambled egg that's what
happens when you are on top of the
mounted cooking and there we go the most
amazing scrambled egg pocket fat and
okay yes come here for breakfast it
normally read potatoes
wait winner when hot enough so made with
the whole pack of fat
you normally potatoes for breakfast in
we scrambled eggs
as your cook let me know in the comments
what you think of that amazing scrambled
egg dish and if you missed uncharted
trust me you can watch it on the link
below or on the Nat Geo app